-We have exactly
three shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters".
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Three days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between now
and Christmas
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member a bodacious
Christmas sweater from the
Countdown to Christmas cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
And since there are
three shows left, let's open
door number three.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh!
-Ooh.
-Wow.
♪♪
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
[ Chuckles ]
Wow.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hm.
Beautiful.
All right, now let's see
who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
302.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on down!
♪♪
There you go.
Hello!
Hello. How're you doing?
-Good. Nice to meet you.
-Nice to see you.
What is your name?
-Jackie.
-Jackie, where are you from?
-Long Island.
-Long Island!
I love Long Island.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know it gets a little chilly
out in Long Island.
You have a beautiful sweater.
-Thank you.
-But it's missing -- it has a
couple of beautiful holes in it.
[ Laughter ]
I think this --
you'll need this in Long Island.
And you'll just fit right in.
No one will even know
you're wearing it.
-No one will know.
-Would you like to try it on
right now for everyone?
-Absolutely.
-Oh, this is gonna be fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here you go.
There's no right way
to put it on,
I gotta be honest.
Well, you got your arms in
the sleeve, that's a win.
-Thanks.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Look at you.
Look at this.
You look gorgeous.
Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] You look beautiful.
Oh, my gosh.
Is that not fantastic?
Happy holidays.
It's nice to see you.
Thank you for coming
to the show.
You look great.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You can go right up
to your seat.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you so much.
-[ Laughs ]
That's the best.
[ Laughing ]
Can we get a camera shot
of her going --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
[ Laughs ]
And you don't even know
what's happening.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you look great.